[Music]
in the world of math many strange
results are possible when we change the
rules but there's one rule that most of
us have been warned not to break
don't divide by zero
how can the simple combination of an
everyday number and a basic operation
cause such problems
normally dividing by smaller and smaller
numbers gives you bigger and bigger
answers
10 divided by 2 is 5 by 1 is 10 by 1
millionth is 10 million and so on so it
seems like if you divide by numbers that
keep shrinking all the way down to zero
the answer will grow to the largest
thing possible then isn't the answer to
10 divided by zero actually infinity
that may sound plausible but all we
really know is that if we divide ten by
a number that tends towards zero the
answer tends towards infinity
and that's not the same thing as saying
that ten divided by zero is equal to
infinity why not well let's take a
closer look at what division really
means
ten divided by two could mean how many
times must we add two together to make
ten or two times what equals 10
dividing by a number is essentially the
reverse of multiplying by it in the
following way
if we multiply any number by a given
number x we can ask if there's a new
number we can multiply by afterwards to
get back to where we started
if there is the new number is called the
multiplicative inverse of x
for example if you multiply three by two
to get six you can then multiply by one
half to get back to three so the
multiplicative inverse of two is one
half and the multiplicative inverse of
ten is one tenth
as you might notice the product of any
number and its multiplicative inverse is
always one
if we want to divide by zero we need to
find its multiplicative inverse which
should be one over zero
this would have to be such a number that
multiplying it by zero would give one
but because anything multiplied by zero
is still zero such a number is
impossible so zero has no multiplicative
inverse
does that really settle things though
after all mathematicians have broken
rules before for example for a long time
there was no such thing as taking the
square root of negative numbers
but then mathematicians defined the
square root of negative 1 as a new
number called i
opening up a whole new mathematical
world of complex numbers
so if they can do that couldn't we just
make up a new rule
say that the symbol infinity means one
over zero and see what happens
[Music]
let's try it imagining we don't know
anything about infinity already based on
the definition of a multiplicative
inverse zero times infinity must be
equal to one that means zero times
infinity plus zero times infinity should
equal two
now by the distributive property the
left side of the equation can be
rearranged to zero plus zero times
infinity
and since 0 plus 0 is definitely 0 that
reduces down to 0 times infinity
unfortunately we've already defined this
as equal to 1 while the other side of
the equation is still telling us it's
equal to two so
one equals two
oddly enough that's not necessarily
wrong it's just not true in our normal
world of numbers
there's still a way it could be
mathematically valid if one two and
every other number were equal to zero
but having infinity equal to zero is
ultimately not all that useful to
mathematicians or anyone else
there actually is something called the
riemann sphere that involves dividing by
zero by a different method but that's a
story for another day
in the meantime dividing by zero in the
most obvious way doesn't work out so
great but that shouldn't stop us from
living dangerously and experimenting
with breaking mathematical rules to see
if we can invent fun new worlds to
explore
for more mind-bending math check out
this playlist
[Music]